[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
hello everyone and welcome to game
sports coverage of e3
and play for 2021 it feels like it gets
earlier and earlier every year so that's
why we're here to kind of
sneak up front and announce what we're
doing for the whole month of june as
well as discuss what you'll be able to
see
during e3 week i'm lucy james joined by
timor hussein
hello it's e3 time baby where is elvin
ring
miyazaki don't worry i've set aside time
to talk about please respond i sent you
my nudes
your what what
what a new baby uh i'm here for uh what
am i here for uh final fantasy 14.
let's go i'm the end walker trailer
again
and jordan mermaid hello i i'm i'm just
here
my my dream game already isn't showing
up at e3
so disappointed
it's not fair before this even began
one of these days hollow knight silson
will
eventually rise from the ashes um but
there are plenty of events
going to be happening throughout the
whole month of june of course we're
throwing our own play for all
there's e3 there's numerous showcases we
have a
calendar up on site where you can see
all the cool important stuff happening
but we're also going to run you through
it right now because there's a lot of
stuff happening and there's a lot of
speculation that we can spend time
talking about and of course
we can talk about all the cool plans
that we have because we have been very
very busy so e3 technically kicks off i
guess tomorrow we've got indie live expo
and the gorilla collective day one we're
not going to talk about every event in
depth because there are
so many and we only really have an hour
but let's talk about let's kick off
with netflix geeked week which kicks off
june 7th
through to the 11th tam i'm going to
come to you first
what can we expect from netflix geek
tweak
i mean i expect we'll see more of the
witcher that's the big thing
i feel like the witcher is what they've
kind of built this event around
um given the success of the first season
and it's well warranted success that
season turned out to be really good and
henry cavill
the man's got uh can use his arms as
guns and also
play a good mean girl which is which is
great but i think there's a few things
other kind of in the cut that are also
really really exciting namely
uh the cuphead show which has been in
production for a little while and
uh undoubtedly is going to be really
really exciting given the art style that
they seem to be sticking quite close to
um resident evil um what was it called
again
well resident evil welcome to raccoon
city there are zombies here please help
us
or something like that it's got the
weirdest title
right there it's got it's got it's
straight up got a really weird title
um and it is baffling uh but
that um and then infinite big ones
infinite dark noises no there's isn't
that oh there's another one
there's another one yeah there's like
it's got a genuine it's like a full
sentence you're thinking about you look
it up
i'm thinking of the movie oh you're
thinking of the movie what's the movie
called
i think it's called some resident evil
welcome to raccoon city
welcome to raccoon city that's the one
uh
yeah so uh infinite darkness
um i mean not not marginally abandon him
there
uh and then castlevania um
castlevania in the middle of rewatching
castlevania because i
started up season four and i just
couldn't remember what was happening so
i've started up again
and i thought season four was supposed
to be it so
are we getting like a spider so we're
getting just more i think
i think there's going to be a spin-off
uh
i mean like they there are certain
things happening around the writer of
the
castlevania script that was used to
adapt it into the netflix series
and i think uh there is an interest in
continuing the castlevania series but
also
figuring out how to do it without being
linked to
uh something that could be potentially
controversial
um that's my understanding
of it that's not an official
understanding of it uh it's not been
uh clarified as that but that's what i
think
um and then and then beyond that
i'm just gonna leave that for people to
research educate yourselves
i must say listen to that peter speak as
he just talks around like
he knows he already knows uh and then
beyond that we got
the sandman exciting i know
together and i know that sandman and
cowboy bebop
not gaming but oh my god i'm so excited
about them especially because they just
announced the same one
cast cowboy bebop they're
cowboy and brian as bebop
[Laughter]
shout out to our ign friends there um
yeah but we should hopefully get a
trailer for that i would love to see a
trailer for that
um and yeah i really hope they do a sort
of orchestral breakdown
of uh tank yeah yeah
tank yeah just like a slow a slow beat a
slow yeah exactly
the violins rising have classified the
ghost
have the ghost of tsushima flute guy in
there as well just be like i'm back i'm
still getting work
um wow and then obviously uh it's being
hosted by
uh rahul cauley um
uh the homie roll uh yuri lointhal
you're scared jeff keeley jeff keeley as
well who you may know
as as many roles such as
jeff keeley at the game awards jeff
keeley at game trailers
jeff keeley at twitter.com
uh jeff keeley's summer games fest
that's happening
we will be talking about summer game
first uh very shortly so yeah so kicking
off
the month huge with netflix geek week
but then on june
9th 7am pt we've got the battlefield
6 review uh review god welcome
that would be one he'll have a
turnaround battlefield six
reveal so unfortunately this one's had
um a couple of leaks
um but michael are you excited about any
battlefield
i mean i i i have a long history with
the battlefield franchise i think well
battlefield 1942 is actually one of my
first pc games i was like blown away by
it
and i reviewed battlefield 5 when it
came out and uh
i don't know i have i have an affinity
for that large-scale combat that they
always do because they always do it
right
um but it's not you know it's not
necessarily enough to do
that core uh gameplay right anymore
because we've we've had it time and time
again of course
which is great and then they need to
nail that down but whatever it is
i'm not i'm not going to play a backseat
developer and kind of like
be like oh they need to do this need to
do that i just want to i just want to be
surprised by something you know we've
we've been through like all these
different eras we went to world war one
with battlefield one we've had world war
ii multiple times modern combat
we've had 21 42 yo if you all want to
bring back battlefield 21 42
say less but uh i just want to be
surprised by whatever battlefield 6 or
whatever the next
battlefield this next battlefield is
going to be um
because yeah it's uh it's always
exciting to dr
uh drop into um about a new battlefield
game but
um yeah there's just uh i want to be
excited again
yeah and i mean jordan are you surprised
that this announcement is coming now it
doesn't seem like ea's really doing
anything else around e3 maybe this one
should have been saved for something
like a microsoft press conference or do
you think they're just trying to get
get away from all the leaks and just
kind of do things on their own terms
i was a bit surprised to hear about it
i'm
hopeful that the entire reason that
they're like look let's just get
battlefield 6 out there in front of e3
and talk about is because
they have something like major extreme
plan for ea play live like in a month's
time and they don't want
battlefield to get in the way of that
but
i it's weird it's because ea always kind
of like has something
around e3 and they'll talk about like
apex and
whatever they're doing with like
battlefront what respawn is doing we had
that like little
awkward conversation last year it's like
hey uh i mean two years ago it's like
hey respawn we hear you're working on a
star wars games like yup
and that was like all the details we got
but
um it's gonna be interesting to see like
just focusing them just focusing on one
game and then
kind of dipping out of e3 unless they
plan to piggyback off anyone else's
conferences this year i can see them
doing that
i can definitely see a sort of trailer
reveal
gameplay stuff may be coming at this
announcement uh
at the on the ninth and then maybe
something else at microsoft because
typically
you know if you've got that partnership
with a platform holder then you can
leverage some
you know i don't know show off another
trailer or something typically it's
usually card right but card seems to
have moved to
so of sony presentations over the last
few years so who
knows but exciting that they're kind of
just taking ownership of stuff and just
like you know
just not letting the leakers have all
that fun so that's on june 9th
and we've already name-dropped him uh a
bunch also on june 9th is our tech
rehearsal so don't forget that
um oh we've also named up to him a bunch
of times
jeff keeley's summer game fest kickoff
live um is happening june 10th
uh 11am pt right so
so jeff's kind of in this phase now
where he's doing a thing he normally
does for the game awards where he'll
tease out guests
but we don't really have much knowledge
on who is going to be there sort of from
the gaming side because we know that
weezer is going to be performing we know
that japanese breakfast is going to be
performing
very excited about that and then we've
got
jeff goldblum uh is gonna be presenting
something and then there's also gonna be
day of the devs
which is an event that i miss very very
dearly like that's always
such a fun thing to go to in san
francisco and i'm really glad they can
have dave the devs as part of summer
game fest
but then there he's he's just got to
think that he's just calling world
premiere showcase and i'm going to go
around the room
first of all to do everyone's best world
premiere voice
yeah michael's already kind of gone
there jordan jump the gun
world premiere probably kalisto protocol
i can see it
world premiere oh
a little bit like a little cheer i don't
know about energy
a little spice thrown in there yeah
world premiere
no i used to be able to do the xbox
voice quite well like
now from three four three industries
like that woman
but anyway who do we think is gonna be
on
jeff's stage uh as part of summer game
first kick off
live michael it's gonna be
uh i wish i wanted to be yokotaro
showing off drakengard 4 but that's not
going to happen
so i think it's probably going to be uh
i don't know maybe like the the we're
going to get more information on
dragon age four i don't know from dragon
guard to dragon age four
i do i mean yeah i mean bioware has
done a lot of stuff with jeff's shows in
the past like obviously we saw the new
mass effect
i think game wards is where they
revealed dragon age 4 officially
so i don't think that's too far out of
the realm of possibility
what do you think do you think they
would be but dragon age 4
well should come first i mean maybe but
i i guess like if
they're riding the high of mass effect
legendary edition which obviously sort
of just came out a few weeks ago
that i've seen people on twitter kind of
wondering if they would put the mass
effect 3 multiplayer as a separate
announce but i'm
i don't know jordan fellow mass effect
aficionado what do you think about rumor
part of me wants to believe it and the
other part of me is like there's
there's no way that they actually give
us the mass effect 3 multiplayer
like there's there's no way bioware
looks at it and it's like yeah i think i
think we can bring the multiplayer back
and we can support it and people will
play it and it'll be good and like
people are still playing it though the
people are still playing
but like are enough are enough people
still playing are enough people still
playing it they're like let's bring back
and fully support
an entire like multiplayer component
while we're
at the same time working on mass effect
4
and dragon age 4. like that's a that's a
lot of moving parts
and i think bioware kind of at least i
hope they want to focus
on making sure that they actually get a
really
good well-received game out there that's
not a remaster of games that people
already like
i don't know i kind of secretly i
secretly hope because i did have a lot
of fun playing mass effect 3 multiplayer
back in the day i know a lot of people
did
so i don't think it's out i don't know
i'm
cautiously hopeful i think it would just
be like you know big march simpson vibes
but i just think that's neat
uh tam what do you think jeff might pull
out of the bag
at summer game fest you know what i want
to say
everyone knows what i want to say but i
am going to say it
i mean i was going to say you can you've
got three elden ring
cards use them throughout this i've got
i'm like i'm like uh i'm like a yu-gi-oh
player but like every card is elden ring
it's like a pot of greed i'm just doing
everything i can
to keep using pot of green uh i'm gonna
say
i'm gonna i'm gonna get a bit weird with
it
persona 5 on pc
oh wow okay wow not on switch though
uh yeah for some reason persona 5
appears on
on pc hell yeah pulling that out of out
of the
air i mean
i honestly also
could see it happening yeah i like it
before
p4g is already out there yeah and like
yeah
uh jordan i asked you about mass effect
3 multiplayer but is there anything else
you would definitely
want to see jeff uh i don't know why i'm
making him out to be some kind of wizard
with a hat
at this point but i guess he kind of is
it's like you get a heart and you get a
brain
uh it's it's not gonna happen but
it would be wild if vin diesel came out
to
intro a new trailer for arc 2. that
would be dope
i would like that i would like that i i
mean
that seems realistic they came out to do
the fast game right
at game awards a couple years ago so
also there was a new fast game announced
like a few days ago right
how about this vin diesel appears on
stage
and introduces elden ring oh
my gosh there's a character in elden
ring
he's like i'm in elden ring i'm a boss
he's like you think you know me i did
group i'm group
you think i can't do any voice acting
that's sick
i mean no it's not he's the voice of the
ring
first it wouldn't be the first time that
a famous
fan has been put into a souls game
like peter serafinowicz british actor
very big fan was in dark souls 2. so
hey i'm i'm willing to bet i'm willing
to bet everything i own
that vin diesel is absolute ass at all
souls games i bet he's terrible so i
don't think he's a fan but i would i
would
love it if he was just in there i don't
know if i'd
i won't smoke with vin diesel on a live
stream bro but that's all you like
i can take vin diesel i think i could
take bindies or
easy easy clap okay as someone as
someone who has just recently watched
through
every fast and furious movie within a
week and a half
i'm gonna have to have you stop talking
about dom turret out like
that because he he's my boy he's family
um any other surprises that we think i
know i've really ascended to a different
plane and on that plane i live a quarter
mile at a time
uh anything else that we think from
summer game fest like it's
he's keeping it very very under wraps
and it's kind of difficult to know
what exclusives jeff has managed to nab
away from the other showcases that we're
expecting during
anyone have any e3 could expect
something like baldur's gate 3 being
announced that it's coming
out of early access later this year like
in october wasn't divinity original sin
2 in early access only for a year
so maybe they're doing the same for
police day 3.
there's definitely going to be some
fortnite stuff there you know it
like um he always usually has some sort
of fortnite thing going on right
so imagine work
among us right so he could yeah i would
say i would genuinely love it if he
wasn't
i'd love it if they did like a lore
video about the uh the bus
and he's the driver of the bus the
entire time
oh so you've been thanking jeff keeley
the entire time
oh damn all right
let's move on from summer game first
live kickoff
uh let's talk a little bit about the i
still don't know how to pronounce this
is it clutch media
coke couch me yeah i mean there are
different pronunciations depending on
where you are in the world but clutch
media is june 11th
12 p.m pt and as i was putting together
this run of show i was like
maybe saints row maybe dead island maybe
metro
maybe time splitters earlier today deep
silver tweeted
our parent company at koch media hq is
making an announcement as part of summer
games fest
on june 11th to give you a heads up you
won't see dead island saints row metro
or time splitters here
or at any or at any other e3
2021 event or everything we have
news to share why are you why are you
announcing that
why are you announcing that announcement
by the way everyone all of our most
anticipated games
none of them the biggest
anti-announcement
i did think it would be too soon for
time splitters because they
you know just kind of renounced re
invigorated free radical fairly recently
so i did think
the most you'd get from time splitters
would maybe be some kind of cgi trailer
but yeah i don't really know what else
the
you know big big stuff that koch media
has that they would want to be
publishing this yet maybe a sequel to
manitoba
they're going to have a presentation and
vin diesel is gonna come out and he's
gonna say
it's pronounced [ __ ] media and then he's
gonna leave
and that's the end of the show i mean
i don't hate it i honestly if
vin diesel does appear at e3 it's some
in some capacity i'd absolutely love
that i think
man that would generally just really
just elevate e3 for me so yeah so coach
media
does anyone else have any other ideas of
what they could bring out for that
showcase
did you say man i was writing on saints
row yeah maddie who says no saints bro
even though they did just remaster uh
was it four or three they just brought
no they were master three again
i think for like this one yeah
yeah i mean i i yeah i don't even know
why i didn't go on the website
was sequel to eight fastest
fast furious is going into
space then saints row can deal with
their whole time travel
steal that they tease at the end of four
absolutely yeah
that's what's up yeah asians of mayhem
you know the vibes
oh my god maybe we'll get an agent of
mayhem too
no i don't think so but i mean
we also have home friend god damn you
also have home front but i don't
think there's gonna be another home
front announcement at least that's not
on my e3 bingo card at all what i will
say
is that this level of uncertainty is
kind of exciting you know
it's uh it's nice to not know yeah i
mean like i want to be excited
i'm tired of knowing everything
well it's funny you say that because
june 12th
uh we've got gorilla collective day two
and the wholesome direct wholesome
direct is
genuinely please watch it it's such a
great collection of really wholesome
games and such a nice message behind it
uh so that's at 10 am pt on june 12th
but speaking of knowing everything
uh 12 pm pt on june 12th we've got
ubisoft forward
uh far cry
6. um did you i mean let's go around the
room what do we all think of the far cry
6
uh kind of showcase that they had was it
last week they showed off a little bit
of gameplay
talked a little bit more about how it's
not political then backtracked and said
jk it is a bit but within
a limit um time would you
why do you make a far cry 6 and what
what do you think they're going to be
showing
here at e3 um i think they'll probably
just show off way more of the gameplay i
i expect they'll have a very character
focused moment
they're always chasing the old vast
moment
eternally that that franchise has now
become a franchise that desperately
year after year tries to find a new vas
um and
i think we'll probably get a bit more of
that with a whole bunch of new
gameplay to show off the weird um uh
kind of customization and crafting that
you can do
what did i think of the showcase i
thought it was absolutely fine like
uh far cry is one of those games where
it's like it doesn't
it hasn't done anything new in a while
in a major way
but that's still kind of okay the core
here is a gamepl cry game i would be
like i will play this far cry game for a
little bit
and um yeah so you know
in that respect i'm i'm i'm interested
in seeing what more they show
um based on the preview that we had it
doesn't look like it's doing anything
massively different which is like
okay then okay so obviously it was
supposed to come out
in the the first half of this year it
ended up being delayed and now it's kind
of sitting pretty
in that typical assassin's creed slot
uh jordan do you think we're gonna get
any rumblings of a new assassin's creed
i know they're not necessarily going
annually anymore but do you think we'll
even get a hint
if we get anything assassin's creed
it'll be a
new trailer and release date for the
siege of paris expansion for valhalla
that's their big next thing and it's
tentatively scheduled for
summer 2021 i have no idea if they're
still gonna
hit that but i i assume we'll hear about
that and
probably nothing else for assassin's
creed i would love it if they teased at
least
something about what they're thinking
about next for their next trilogy of
assassin's creed games but
i i don't expect it i'm not getting my
hopes up for it
i feel really guilty because i was
really really enjoying valhalla
and then um the game just never ended so
i oh it's a long game
yeah exactly well i i started it and
then i saw like someone i think it was
you jordan you were like i
am 70 hours in and i think i'm near the
end i was like
i'm done i'm good you died i'm not
coming it's i'm not coming
brevity games industry please brevity
uh so we've got far cry we might have
information on the assassin's creed
stuff uh
rainbow six quarantine was announced uh
wow a couple years ago at this point and
then obviously
couldn't necessarily come out last year
given
the events um but we i mean
hopefully we'll see more of it during
ubisoft
forward michael are you excited for
rainbow six quarantine
uh i'm straight i'm i'm blue off that i
don't know i'm not really like a like a
zombie survival kind of shooter
guy i love rainbow six siege that's just
fire but uh
i don't know like maybe more siege
content see what's next uh for rainbow
six siege that'd be tight
um that's cool but uh i don't know
i i feel like i feel like there's more
immediately
exciting things that i mean not say that
like rainbow six quarantine won't be
fire but like uh i feel like there's
like bigger hitters that we can uh
that we can kind of tease out of ubisoft
please bring back splinter cell in some
capacity
or like um i think who someone said on
twitter that we should just like have a
burial
like a ceremony for uh sam fisher r.i.p
okay
um you know it's i think that's like i i
think that is the best idea i've heard
in a long time like if the entire gaming
community like across
twitch and everywhere were like this is
uh national
r.i.p sam fisher day ubisoft will have
to say something
like they will have to be like no he's
not dead he's not dead that'll be right
we should just act like ubisoft has
killed sam fisher
and like hold him accountable for it by
holding like a memorial for him
and and then he want to see
yeah exactly that's the only way we're
getting sam fisher at this point we're
getting a new splinter cell
because damn oh my god you know what
they
all they should do like they should do
like a splinter cell remastered like
final fantasy 7 remake or like
splitter cell remake yo like all of the
at least the original three games
just remake them in like the most modern
engine yo
because when was when was original
2002. yeah yeah
wildlands because it's the 20th
anniversary of
xbox and splinter obviously was like
xbox a game at the beginning i do wonder
if it's like hey and for xbox's 20th
anniversary we'll do a split sell thing
but that's just
wishful thinking at this point i don't
know i mean it's
i i hope that they must see the outcry
about splinter cell like
we know ea did and that's why we're
getting skate 4. so you've got to hope
someone there at ubisoft is like
maybe we should do this it seems like
there's an audience for it
um but also we need to do
is every time someone at ubisoft says oh
no we hear you
sam is alive you just need to reply with
stop lying to us
stop lying to us like stop because they
keep doing it they're like we understand
in a french accent they say we
understand that there is a
a love for sam fisher and there's a
demand for it and we are thinking of
wait no you're not
stop lying to us
they know that they can't turn splinter
cell into a giant
big open world game the same way that
they can
far cry and coast recon but do you want
that
you want an 80 hour splinter cell game
in the same scope of assassin's creed
valhalla which is like one of ubisoft's
best-selling
games like because that's what you've
said
metal gear solo 5 was a solid like 30 40
hours
and it was amazing so
i'm telling ubisoft doesn't want that
they want the 60 to 90 hour experience
i feel like a school teacher who has
lost control of the class
so
uh because we've got like about half
hour left that we start to talk about
microsoft nintendo
um square and like all the stuff that
we're doing so i'm just gonna move us
along
quickly but in terms of ubisoft there
are still a bunch of question marks on
certain games
such as beyond good and evil too skull
and bones which
i god who knows what is even happening
with skull bones um
one thing i think we definitely can
expect though from ubisoft forward
is a just dance so that's honestly i
just love how much the just dance team
loves just dance because those bits are
always
so colorful and so fun and uh
you know i will pay all of you five
dollars if
it's not there do you think
the way that ubisoft looks at just dance
just
like absolute adoration
do you think we'll see a non-ubisoft
original at the
showcase like it's like here's something
here's something made by a developer
that ubisoft is publishing but like
we're not making it
the next naruto open world game
uh i just remembered prince of persia
they showed that game and the entire
gaming community went what is this
and they went uh you never saw that
we're just gonna
bring that back bad because like isn't
that ubisoft india's like
first game like as a lead studio so i
really hope they get it right because
they've been given something that so
many people love and it's like one of
those games that is very much
just held with such reverence and so i
hope we get to see more of prince of
persia now we've had more
time to work on it but like i said i'm
going to skip us forward uh there's a
gearbox event
i assume it's going to be movie stuff
there have been uh
rumors on twitter that there's going to
be some kind of borderlands spin-off but
i also think they're going to take this
opportunity
to maybe show jamie leaker as how to use
a camera
and actually show the characters instead
of just the shadows
because it would be good to see what the
actors look like in the movie love you
jamie lee curtis but he's teasing
actually i shouldn't do that jamie lee
curtis does like i think she's great but
i'm
also slightly intimidated by her who
isn't
but is there anything is there anything
else you think is gonna be at this
gearbox
showcase
magic tricks there's gonna be uh randy
on stage
under a spotlight sweating and doing
magic tricks
i hope that is my that's my hope for it
yeah do you really really hope for that
oh yeah who doesn't love to see randy
pitchford doing magic tricks
i love that [ __ ] man because i'm just to
stop
stuck again moves forward also we've got
the devolver digital event
uh but let's move forward to june 13th
10am pt it's the big one it is
xbox and bethesda joining forces
doing a joint games showcase um
like i said earlier it's 20th
anniversary of xbox so i think
everyone is hoping and praying that
they're going to do something big not
only for the anniversary of the console
and as xbox of xbox as a brand but also
you know you've got halo infinite
so quickly go around the room michael
what are your kind of
big uh not takeaways because it hasn't
happened yet but what are your big
expectations for this showcase uh
broadly speaking i think this is
you know i think we every time we see
xbox at a big event it's always like yo
we're anticipating big things from y'all
and like
they've shown promise every at every
show it's like yo we got
studio acquisitions this studio is
working on this but we have nothing to
show yet just be patient
but know that they're working on
something big and i'm looking at the
list that we have here
and there's just so much stuff that they
have um teased or at least introduced or
promised
that no this could be their moment to at
least show off some
some of those promising things such as
like i'm looking at a vowed
uh that's something that was teased out
of obsid like yo that that
obsidian like that could be that could
be a big hitter right there um
you know they teased fable uh maybe we
see a little bit more of that
not not gonna be too wild on that
hellblade 2 was the
was what they premiered the xbox series
x with so
maybe now's the time to kind of show off
a little bit of about what
hellblade 2 is all about and of course
everyone's thinking about halo infinite
you know we were supposed to have that
game last year but of course that that
didn't happen but
um this is an opportunity to kind of be
like yo
we're serious about halo infinite and
this is more
of what it is because there's still a
lot of questions as like what exactly is
going on with halo infinite
in terms of multiplayer and um how
they've they've tweaked the game since
last time we saw it
perfect dark is also on people's minds
but i do think that's a little bit more
ways off since we were just teased for
that but there's just so much exciting
stuff out there and like that's not even
touching on what bethesda's working on
you know
i think everyone's thinking about star
field death loop is around the corner
yeah we're we're all i don't we are all
hyped for that
but i think starfield is probably uh and
ghostwire are probably the two things
that
we might see prominently at the showcase
i hope so but
whatever they're showing off it's
probably gonna be i would say it's gonna
be a big deal
yeah i agree i mean i'm cautiously
optimistic that we'll see
ghostwire but i also feel like they've
gone very very
quiet since we last saw it and i do
wonder if it's going to hit this year
um but i think if they are going to
announce that it is going to slip into
2022 we'll hopefully get a more
meatier look at it um perhaps shinji
mikami will be
on stage or something to discuss it uh
jordan what are your hopes and dreams
for xbox
slash bethesda uh i'm i'm really hoping
that we get
a some actual release dates or some at
least deeper dives into the games that
xbox slash bethesda are thinking about
releasing like
while we're waiting for those giant
games to hit while we're waiting for
halo infinite while we're waiting for
fable while we're waiting for a vowed so
things like
12 minutes it finally deserves a release
date what's that new universe that the
we happy few compulsion games folks
are working on stalker two like what's
going on with that like i
i want to know what's going on with
those games they're coming from first
party studios that
or are like exclusive to the xbox
console platform like 12 minutes
that are that don't quite carry the same
weight as something like
halo infinite or fable but will help
like
carry the xbox brand and carry xbox game
pass while we wait for
those games to come out yeah i think i
think it's gonna be a good mix i think
now is the time given that it's been two
three years since they announced all
those acquisitions
um and obviously they massively
increased their roster of first party
studios
i think now is going to be the time that
we start to see something from
compulsion we start to see you know what
uh double fine are working on beyond
psychonauts and kind of the future of
those studios is going to start to
trickle out
and i think as well it's just sort of
this is xbox's time where it's like hey
we're 20. this is everything we've done
so i think there's definitely going to
be a lot of legacy stuff i think we're
going to see
obviously you see the future of halo but
we'll see stuff hopefully from things
like gears gears 5 obviously ended on
a cliffhanger that i'm still thinking
about so maybe we'll see the future of
gears but i think also this is the time
where xbox are firmly going to be like
and this is all the cool stuff we're
working on um
today i'm going to throw to you what do
you think is going to be at
xbox i think there's going to be a very
like
i think you you folks are right about
everything you said i think it's going
to be a very halo infinite focused
uh presentation i think that's the big
game that they will be kind of
booking like but i think they're going
to book in the um
the presentation with halo a whole chunk
of it to show
almost undo the last presentation where
it was like
why does this grunt and why does this
elite look like this and why is
what's going on here so like they're
gonna be like they want everyone to walk
away from that press conference
going holy [ __ ] halo is going to be
amazing i need to
mine bitcoin and figure out a way to get
an xbox series x
or whatever it may be and then i think
that's going to be them a major deal for
them and then starfield
is going to be the other thing where
it's like hey this is what the bethesda
acquisition is going to give us
this is going to be on game pass this is
i don't know mass effect this is you
know their mass effect basically or
something like that
that's what i'm imagining it to be so i
think those two are going to be the big
deal and then bam elden ring right at
the end there it is
everyone's gonna be like holy sh
miyazaki comes out on stage
and just goes hello and then leaves and
then they play
the elven ring trailer um we obviously
had an interview with
big phil uh a little while ago and he
had
he said he'd been playing it so i
imagine my man was
over there playing the game seeing it to
kind of figure out where they can
introduce it
and my money is on if it's if elder ring
is showing up at e3
i've got a strong suspicion it'd be at
microsoft's press conference
and it will i'm just going to go all
out and say there will be a release date
wow so you think eldon ring just kind of
moves into that slot that cyberpunk has
held in the xbox conference elden ring
is the new year
cyberpunk yeah let's not say that
well let's not operate who's the keanu
reeves equivalent it's vindy's
that would be i think that's it i think
those those will be and then
i think in between they'll have stuff
like uh we've got
15 seconds of fable it's like the
stingers they need to only show a fable
they still need to show off forza they
still need to show off
like you said uh perfect dark i think
they could show the crimson omen
for for gears and just be like it still
exists
and then obviously they end with the big
one
geometry wars i don't know
okay yeah i think i think xbox and uh
bethesda is going to be a big one that's
i think that's the press conference i'm
looking forward to the most
um i think i just i just want them to
have a really good year
um at e3 they've kind of because i mean
they had a few years with it was kind of
a lull but it seems like they're really
picking up momentum so
i'm just sort of desperate to see what
fable looks like at this point
because i'm british and that's where i
hold my affinity but moving on
square enix has announced a showcase to
uh 12 15
on the 13th so they've actually kind of
come out and said what
everything is pretty much going to be so
we've got avengers update
uh babylon's fall life is changed true
colors
and uh idos montreal's brand new
game so we'll talk a little bit about
that in a second
but do you guys have high hopes for this
presentation like it feels like they've
laid out quite clearly what they're
going to be showing um is that a good
idea to kind of temper expectations like
that
michael yeah i i think i'm kind of glad
that they they said that this is what
they're going to show off because
if otherwise i'd be on the edge of my
seat looking for what's next from final
fantasy
16. and also i just want to see the end
the final fantasy 14 and walker trailer
again so if they're not going to show
that you know just tell me straight up
uh this is one this is one area where i
don't want to be surprised with this
appointment
uh so naoki yoshida hit me up uh we've
been you know we've been talking a lot
bro so uh
you know my email you know my twitter
handle let me know what's good with
final fantasy 16
um but uh i mean there there is one
thing like what's idos montreal working
on like that's the surprise thing that
i'm i'm eager for
uh and also avalon's fall bro yo so
that's the new platinum games joint that
we haven't seen
like two or three years at this point uh
i
i think i said this on gay spot after
dark uh our our
wonderful weekly podcast here at
gamespot which you all should be
listening to
i think i've heard some rumblings about
what babylon's fall
is and that's that on that
i'm intrigued
uh jordan what are you excited for from
this presentation
i i just want
some sort of actual
plan for avengers i want them to
come out on stage and be like hey
this game did not release probably the
way that we wanted it to and we've had a
little bit of trouble getting out the
content that we promised
here is like all of our goals that we're
going to hit
content-wise for avengers over the next
year because spider-man still isn't even
in the game and like he's not even on
the road map anymore and i'm like
what's up what is happening to avengers
i
i i'm not even playing it anymore like i
just
because i'm like i don't even know
what's happening with this game i just
want
some sort of plan so i know when i can
jump back into avengers and start
grinding the characters that i want to
grind to play the content that i want to
play that's
that's all i just i want some sort of
idea of what's happening with that game
and time what about you what are you
excited for
uh i mean every event that square enix
holds that doesn't involve
the legacy of kane is an event that is a
absolute failure to me so um
the legacy is the same as the longest
what if that's what
is doing what if i don't during legacy
of kane i
i will take it i will take it all back
and i will um
tell i will send a a letter to the head
of square enix
apologizing for my words but until that
happens
get a grip square enix um beyond that
uh stop holding the one of the greatest
franchises of all time hostage
there's a lot of hostage talk this
morning yeah deus ex
um kill a final fantasy for a foreign
a final fantasy there's there's like
wacky final fantasies on mobile
happening right now so we can we can
lose this yeah
um but like honestly like i really want
to see
yeah i want to see babylon's fall the
most and the idos montreal thing
and babylon's fall obviously because i
love platinum games so
i'm desperate to see that and like
michael i have heard some interesting
things about that game
so i i hope that they show it off
because then everyone
should i miss a memo or something but
yeah i was going to say that
because we have to be part of the japan
game obsessed
crew that we have ah i see i'm not weeb
enough then wow
this says the full word waifu's in the
background shut up
don't call me out
that day as well we've also got a look
at back full blood from
warner brothers uh very very quickly on
this one before we move on to nintendo
but do we think
there's gonna be a chance that we get to
see more suicide squad and gotham
knights
if dc fandom is happening this year do
you think they're still gonna take
advantage of the oh and hogwarts legacy
is
no i totally forgot all those games
existed oh my god
they're owned by the discovery channel
now so what we're gonna see is like
whales just like floating through water
and like documentaries on
on flowers and [ __ ] oh my god i thought
you meant like the country whales
and i was really confused giant open
world
no i reckon they're saving a lot of
welshman
i reckon they're saving that for their
fandom uh the dc fandom yeah
uh where all the all the kind of like
good stuff is gonna be
like why would if you've got batman why
would you share
your why would you share the spotlight
um with
all these other games when you can take
it to the place where the batman nerds
are gonna be
and will lose their [ __ ] um so
and same for the suicide squad so it
makes perfect sense for them to stick to
dc
fandom for that
that's fun um all right let's move on
june 15th
9 am pt we have a nintendo direct
uh per a tweet from nintendo tune in for
nintendo direct with roughly 40 minutes
of info focused exclusively on nintendo
switch
software mostly releasing in 2021
followed by around three hours of
gameplay on treehouse
so it's zelda's 35th anniversary
is it the time are we gonna see more
breath of the wild two
beyond a trailer
a nod from town unsure face from michael
yeah obviously we've got sky with sword
yeah
yeah because like yeah cause people are
thrilled about that
whoa damn uh
i don't know i i feel like we we've
we've got the teaser for breath of the
wild too or the breath of wild sequel so
i mean why not show a little bit more
now even if
so the thing is like nintendo's very
direct if you will
about what what before their
presentation like okay this is what
we're focusing on it's going to be this
this and that
releases software only no switch pro so
shut y'all asses up
and then um what's coming out in 2021 so
i feel like maybe we'd only see breath
of the wild too
if it's going to be a 2021 release i
would doubt that
um but i don't know maybe it's easier uh
but there's like there there are a lot
of other things that i think uh folks
are anticipating that we've been
anticipating for a while
uh so i don't know maybe that's like how
they their big bang that they end at the
the end of the presentation before they
go into their
kind of gameplay showcase
very briefly because you mentioned it
there switch pro obviously this showcase
is gonna be
software only the rumor mill has been
working overtime do we think switch pro
is gonna get announced
before e3 tam
yes they've done this before well
they've been like oh this is gonna
this is gonna be this specific uh game
that we're gonna talking about
and then at the end of it they just
slide in like two other games and you're
like you said
you said this was not going to be about
so i reckon
i reckon they will absolutely show it
off
if not it would be likely during the
direct if it's going to be anywhere but
if not
the kind of like treehouse stuff that
they have in the coming time afterwards
i imagine will be will be somewhere
there um beyond that i like
i think it's about time we saw like a
couple of seconds of metroid prime
please
um because you can't keep like just
and also bayonetta what's the deal where
is brianna
i think it's been four years from now
yeah
exactly and um yeah i reckon i hope that
we do see some of that
we see more of that but yeah i i reckon
we will see some breath of the wild too
as well
um people people gonna be very angry if
they don't show up
i was gonna say i know that um at the
last nintendo direct they had a couple
months ago they did kind of mention you
know development's still ongoing
um please you know don't yell at us on
twitter.com
um but i think e3 is probably the place
to show it if they are going to but what
do we think that means because it is
uh there are so many nintendo
anniversaries this year
uh what do we think that means for kind
of other zelda games do we think there's
going to be any more remasters
or perhaps a collection akin to the
weird limited time mario thing they did
for his 35th
jordan what do you reckon bring twilight
princess to switch
please i ask for so little i don't want
skyward sword only evan langer won
skyward swords
i want we have not brought midna back in
any legend of zelda game so the least
you could do is just allow me to relive
the story of twilight princess again
i want so little nintendo if you're not
gonna give me metroid
and i assume you're gonna just deny me
for another year because you love to
tease me with that [ __ ]
then just give me twilight princess
i don't i mean i only want this for you
now
i don't even want it i just want this to
happen for you because we're in hollow
knight
and now this
i'm being denied
that's the thing i mean nintendo always
kind of
strange with how they deal with bringing
old games
to new platforms they typically like to
lock stuff
um do we genuinely think this is
possible that they will put something
like ocarina of time or majora's mask on
the switch
uh or if they're going to be expanding
their backwards compatibility in
any way i'll leave this open to the
floor
so jump in no
they're not going to do that because
it's what everyone wants
i hate it so much
i don't know tam is right and they don't
like us
listen i love nintendo with all my heart
like it's a key part of my gaming
identity
i have come to terms with the fact that
anything that i want
they will not give me they will give me
the opposite of that
so if you want ocarina of time on switch
you know what you're going to get
you're going to get ocarina of time
wallpapers on nintendo.com
that's what you're getting wow wow
before before we move on to it
shouts out to pokemon i think we want to
see more from the two pokemon games that
got lined up it is also still the 25th
anniversary
uh so uh yeah those though i would
expect
at least a little bit of that i mean
[ __ ] it's pokemon so can you imagine
nintendo just doesn't bring any of this
no zelda no metroid no donkey kong no
pokemon
they're just like what why they got some
people games
actually i do really hope they actually
do is like they
create one of the 99 style games that
they've been doing for all their
franchises but do it for zelda like
figure out a way of doing something cool
like zelda 99 um and make a multiplayer
version of that
like they've got four swords and they've
got ideas that they could
like kind of adapt to to make it happen
so i hope they do that just don't make
it a limited time thing where you need
to play it between
certain hours and it's only available
for like half half
a month or something mad nonsense like
that
um but fingers crossed for something
like that
right okay well you've just effectively
meant that we're not going to talk about
elden ring because banana namco is
having a
showcase too just after nintendo
so i don't even know man just show elden
ring it's been too long
but more excitingly gamespot has a
showcase um
i think it right now it's sitting at 3
35 on
june 15th tam do you want to talk a
little bit more about it because you've
been
involved in the planning yeah so it's
the play for all showcase and it is
uh sadly doesn't have any elder ring in
it i tried i failed
um it's instead focused
yeah i did it in all caps and i was like
here are my nudes please
exchange for one trilden ring trailer
and
he did not reply um so
uh the actual showcase is focused on
a lot of indie games and the way we kind
of approached it is we wanted to find
games and developers that represent the
future of the industry
and what that means is we've got a hand
selected
and i genuinely mean hand selected like
i went through
a spreadsheet of so many games
and watched the trailers did research
into them and picked
a bunch of games that i thought and
randy helped
as well on this and and a couple of
folks from the mix that i thought were
really cool
and they are games that either are made
by diverse teams
touch on themes that are important or
they kind of have representation
of uh characters or ideas or narratives
that are a little more diverse and from
around the world
um inclusivity is a big part of the
game's uh
the kind of theme of the the showcase
and we really nailed down
um games that would speak to that so
it's about 20 games it's gonna last
about an hour long and
in between the kind of awesome game
trailers that we're going to be showing
we'll have interviews with uh select
developers that are going to be there
there's a whole bunch of really really
cool games the stuff that i know that i
love
and it's loved seeing and i know that i
picked it based on
oh i know there's going to be a bunch of
people that are really going to be
excited to see something like this and
it's going to put a new game on their
radar
um so yeah that's going to be uh about
an hour long and
it's full of a lot of cool stuff so
please be excited
it's hollow knight on this oh that again
it's all when i saw someone there you'll
have to wait
you'll have to wait you have to watch
and find out on
june 15th uh so not only are we doing
pre and post shows on all of the biggest
press conferences we also are running
two days worth of live streams as part
of play for all in e3 so that's june
16th and 17th so you're going to make
you're going to want to make sure to
come back to gamestop.com youtube.com
gamespot twitch.tv gamespot etc etc
because we're going to be running
interviews with a bunch of devs as well
as exclusive trailers and looks at
gameplay we've also got some
fun little kind of e3 reaction sessions
with folks like
greg miller uh naomi kyle uh steve spahn
and jake baldino and paris lily and so
many more so we're
kind of joined by friends of gamespot to
discuss
e3 in greater detail and then uh
the week after so june 21st to 25th
that's when we're doing our playful
charity live streams so you might
remember last year we went for
six weeks i think we did like one stream
a day for six weeks uh
this time we're doing a week's worth of
streams uh we're doing uh two slots
every day except for friday when we're
going to be doing
a longer stream with our friends over a
giant bomb
so make sure to tune in and find out
we've got some great guests obviously
kind of funny
are going to be part of it uh steve
spahn and folks from rooster teeth and
fun house
and we're working to raise money for
ablegamers this year so
we thought long and hard about the
charity that we were going to be
choosing to raise money for and it's
also 25th anniversary this year and we
wanted to do something to kind of give
give back to the gaming community a
little bit and you know the work that
ablegamers does
is so crucial in this time and i think
definitely highlighted even more
by the impact of the last year is um you
know through talking with steve he's
been
telling us about like people with
disabilities are very isolated
and in events like covid and quarantine
that isolation has just been compounded
and video games
are we all know a fantastic way of
connecting to people like
i moved halfway across the world and i
keep in touch with my friends
by playing games and by the crucial work
that ablegamers does
they open up gaming for so many more
people so we really hope that you'll be
tuning in and donating we're gonna have
a lot of fun
um we're gonna be hopefully raising a
lot of money for their excellent
cause we'll drop the link um in the
description of this video but as well
we'll be tweeting out
um the whole time it'll be a tilt file
link easy to uh
donate so that's what you can expect
from e3 and play for all this june i'm
gonna do a quick
once over around the room uh if my
lovely
co-hosts want to give a shout out to
where folks can find them
over e3 uh michael you're actually going
to be in la
and what your kind of biggest hope for
the show is so mike i'll start with you
all right yeah you can find me in all my
stuff
at p heim on twitter i'll be tweeting
out all about e3
uh and then uh yeah i'm actually part of
the
official uh coverage for e3 so i'm gonna
be
yo your boy's gonna be uh voting on like
the best of show for e3
i'm gonna be on live streams with greg
and uh and uh jackie jing and golden boy
out there
so it's really exciting to be down in la
to feel like i'm part of
an event again like a live production
it's gonna be wild
it's gonna be a ton of fun so not only
is gamespot and all my
my friends and co-workers gonna be doing
their own thing i'll be out there
representing gamespot as well
uh through the official e3 channel so
definitely peep
uh both coverage from the event and game
spot
and uh yeah and my biggest hope is i
don't know
i want to see the final fantasy 14 and
walker trailer again that's it
it's on youtube what's wrong with you i
want to see it again jordan
jordan what about you i would say my e3
plans are not as exciting as michael's
but
as per usual you will probably see my
name on a lot of
bylines in a lot of places on a lot of
news articles as the
streams start uh picking up and
tam and chris are like jordan can you
write this can you write this can you
write this
so yeah uh you'll just see me covering a
lot of stuff and i
my face might appear in a few things
we'll see it's
not completely set in stone uh what am i
mo
uh really all my hopes and dreams for
this e3 have been dashed into the ground
already
but
look if there's not gonna be hollow
knight silk song then what's even the
point you know what i will
give it i will give my hopes and dreams
to tam he's been waiting for elden ring
i hope that he gets
elton ring let's go time going to
quickly pass it over to you
uh yeah i'm going to be doing a lot of
the hosting stuff alongside lucy
and then working in the background to
arrange stuff probably do some writing
here and there as well
and my biggest hope for uh the e3 is a
surprise release date for
um hollow knight silk song for jordan
we look after each other how do you like
that oh my psych is elden ring i always
care about this golden ring
i do not give a [ __ ] about anything else
all right and just like that
i'm moving us on i'm on twitter eastern
games i'm gonna be hosting a lot of the
pre
and post show stuff uh so i'm gonna be
around all over e3
and my biggest hope and dream is that
everyone has a nice time
but also i would love to see eldon ring
thank you so much for watching us uh
on this kind of pre-e3 show showcase i
suppose little kind of teasers what as
to what is to come
over the next month um you can catch all
the latest news gamestop.com
youtube.comgamesbot
on our social and on our twitch and
we'll catch you
across the whole month of june
peace bye
[Music]
you guys are good
[Music]
bye
[Music]
oh
[Music]
hmm
[Music]
so
[Music]
you